mr mike myers how are you sir good how
are you
where are you from i'm so great where
are you from toronto
man i know well that's where we're at
yeah oh there's
there's this thing about ken scarbrough
and there's been really this thing about
canadians where people talk about us as
being nice yeah right and that's that's
a good thing and sometimes it's a joke
but there's
more than surface level to the idea of
being nice
in this movie why was that important to
you to bring out i'm very proud of of
being canadian
and i
you know i've said it before i'll say it
again but elvis costello has a great
song what's so funny about peace love
and understanding
and i think more than important what i
love about being canadian
is that we're not just nice we're
actually kind
and we don't always get it right that's
for sure and and we have a history and
there's stuff i wish had not happened
but for the most part having lived in
three countries in my life i do think
that canada is a very very kind country
and i i've often said
if i wasn't actually canadian i would
want to be canadian
you know there's a
there's a lot of good stuff happening
in canada
uh i can't think of a lot of
other actors that can do what you do
where you take on all these characters
but you become these characters not just
you putting on a costume and we see mike
myers underneath it's like you are who
you you know who you are playing
um
when do you become that person like at
what point in the process do you find
that character well i i
i have to stay in character all day i
have such a thick scar-bro accent
i mean you you will need a blowtorch and
a crowbar to get this accent off me i
will talk like this
forever uh so i have to stay any time i
do something i have to stay
in the accent i'm doing the only other
person i've met is christian bale i just
did
amsterdam the david russell film and uh
which is coming out november
and i am i've got a north american
accent he's playing a north american but
he's british but i have a british accent
in the film and we have to talk to each
other in each other's accent the whole
day
to keep the right ambusher i get warmed
up in the chair the makeup chair is my
time
to get warmed up i i learned this from
martin short
who said that uh when he did sctv
the mirror
had the outside trick the inside
so i i'm very ch
sometimes the makeup takes longer
because i'm so chatty but i love
getting warmed up in the chair i love
staying in character
my heroes peter sellers alec guinness
um
i love the work multiple character work
of eddie murphy fantastic
and uh
phil hartman another canadian from
brantford you know
this is what excites me those creations
you know
i was just talking to debbie and ken
and they were saying that it was a joy
to be there with you and ken was saying
like
he didn't tell you this apparently but
he said to me like he watched austin
powers over and over and over and over
and over again right when when you think
about
the impact of that movie
uh like what strikes you and do you go
back and watch those movies yourself i
tend not to i i have a very personal
life and then i'm also a public person
and i'm in show business i keep those
very separate i grew up very very
working class
to liverpoolians you know
which is the working class of the
working class in england
so i i have a real separation of church
at state
um
i've let my son who's 10 watch austin
powers with guidance
and do a lot of some of the parts
but for the most part they don't really
watch it i don't watch it uh you know
the last 10 years i've just
i have three kids under the age of 10
i've been doing stuff in short bursts
like i did the david russell film
uh you know in glorious bastards
uh
you know um
you know bohemian rhapsody and i did a
documentary on chef gordon out of my
house for three years
this is the first time i've been away
from the family but they're old enough
now
um
you know i i
i am first of all let's talk about ken
jong shall we should we go back to ken
john that man uh the director tim kirkby
is a brilliant brilliant director who
thankfully said yes to do my show
um we both agreed that
ken jong is a special effect
himself
he gives off herbs of energy and if uh
his esprit de corps
he's just funny the only time i saw
somebody that's just that naturally
funny is chris farley
where it's just
a joy to be around
so i am very honored that he's watched
austin powers because i i worship the
ground that he walks on he's so
fantastic
you